when covet 19 first emerged scientists
were scrambling to understand
the deadly disease
searching far and wide for answers
in a distant digital galaxy an unlikely
ally heard the call
an army of gamers were booted up
and ready to play a role in this
pandemic
i have the biggest lab in the world i
have more people working for me as a
scientist
than i think anybody else
our search to find out how gamers are
helping scientists understand kovid led
us to reykjavik iceland
where we found bc native david ecker
he's a production director for ccp games
the makers of the wildly popular online
title
eve
eve online is basically a spaceship
driven mmorpg
so massively multiplayer online game
there's a lot of choice in the roles
that people can play there is a you know
big open market big economy big
community within the game
there can be as many as 250 000 people
around the world playing at the same
time
an armchair army with massive processing
power at their fingertips
kovid's ccp knew it could harness that
power to do more than entertain its
players video games can just be such a
strong conduit for citizen science
to make that happen ecker was put in
touch with another canadian gamer
ryan brinkman who also happens to be a
research scientist at the bc cancer
research center ryan's like the coolest
scientist i think i've ever met or
envisioned he's not just a lab coat kind
of guy on this
[Music]
ryan's day job is building software
tools to help other scientists with
something called flow cytometry close to
data is a technology we use to look at
cells in the blood we use it for
infection for immunity
to understand and develop treatments for
things like cancer covin-19
the plan take information about how
covet infection changes human cells and
turn it into a game where players can
visually identify those altered cells
using real human samples
i didn't have a single data set when we
started i didn't know
where the first data set was going to
come from
those first samples were taken from
hospitals in northern italy where
medical staff were forced to make the
impossible choice
of which patients would live or die
to have it come in right from those
front lines was a bit of a surreal thing
if you really thought about it enough
but it also was you know a motivator for
us to really push this thing out get it
to the users let's really start learning
something
[Music]
the challenge explaining complicated
science in a quick easy and entertaining
way to the gamers that will ensure
valuable scientific results how does
this process work with
covet 19 looking at what the immune
system is responding to or not
responding to when that virus occurs but
we're looking for an increase in the
amount of certain cells or a decrease in
the amount of certain cells
usually a highly trained scientist
manually looks at the cells identifying
the differences between healthy and
unhealthy ones a massively time
consuming task
ryan realized a computer could do it
faster but that requires enough data to
build the right program
that's where the gamers come in they are
providing the information which will
teach the computer what cell patterns to
look for he was able to explain it to us
and then we're able to in turn take that
understanding and explain it to the
thousands of people that are playing our
game
that was kind of a make or break with
this entire thing
the mini game within the game is called
project discovery flow cytometer
in victoria michael daw has been an avid
eve explorer for more than a decade as
an ambassador for the game he wanted to
join the covet fight
and at the same time he was in the
middle of his own battle with cancer
when project discovery came out for the
covid research i was just about to start
chemotherapy so this was near and dear
to my heart it was
something that i felt like i was getting
involved with the science that was
affecting the whole planet
in the flow cytometer game players like
michael are tasked with lassoing a group
of dots they believe are the same type
of cell
i can definitely see that there is a
cluster here so i'm doing my best to
outline it
but i also see a whole bunch of little
dots down here so i'm going to call that
a second cluster and do my best outline
that
we had no idea the power of citizen
science we could be brought to this
problem where people really want to help
and are engaged
gamers have looked at more than 13
million samples the equivalent of over
510 years of work
so that is time that a group of
scientists would actually be having to
crunch the numbers on this
we've taken the data that the gamers
have given us and developed some baby
machine learning algorithms and we've
seen the performance is really
outstripping the current state of the
art which is incredible and we know it's
only get better with the data gets
better it's going to help not only
diagnosis because we don't have to have
really important people drawing circles
around dots explosive is also important
developing treatments treatments not
just for kovid but in the future
advancing research for other illnesses
like cancer i have a lot of pride in eve
online in the fact that we are one of
the pioneers in this that we're trying
to be something more than just a
distraction from reality that we are
helping the real world
by being gamers
at a time when so many are desperately
searching for an escape from this
pandemic
comes a game that proves you can be lost
along the outer edges of a distant
galaxy and still be proudly grounded in
helping humanity
we're making an impact and we're
reaching people
and
it just shows that people care
you